لطالما كان ينتظرها الناس بشغف كل عام
الجمعه السوداء تاتي هذه السنه واوروبا
تعيش وضع اقتصاديا مترديا لكن ازمه تكلفه
المعيشه المتفمه والانشغال بمباريات كاس
العالم لكره القدم دفع بمتاجر التجزئه في
اوروبا للساعي بويه رفع سقف مبيعتها من
خلال تشجيع الناس للاقبال على التخفيضات
بينما تخشى في الوقت نفسه من ان تكون حركه
البيع في موسم عيد الميلاد الاسوا خلال
عقد على الاقل مع احجام المتسوقين على
الانفاق وفي المقابل تزيد تكلفه تشغيل
الاعمال مما يقلص هامش الربح
وهناجر غاضبه تهتف للمطالبه برفع الاجور
وتحسين ظروف العمل
موظفون بشركه امازون الامريكيه العملاقه
نظم احتجاجات واضرابا عن العمل في دول
العده بينها المانيا وفرنسا بالتزامن مع
اهم فترات العامه من حيث معدلات الاقبال
على التسوق الالكتروني في اطار حمله اطلق
عليها اسم جعلوا امازون تدفع الثمن
ووفق بحث اجرته جلوبال داتا فان نحو ربع
المستهلكين في بريطانيا انتهوا بالفعل من
تسوقهم لعيد الميلاد عبر الانترنت بينما
يعتزم متسوق فقط من كل عشره القيام باغلب
مشترياته في الجمعه السوداء